on this episode I talk about kimchi oh
yeah kimchi I talk about preparing for a
public speaking engagement and I talk
about the timing of when this show goes
up everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and you're watching the askgaryvee show
episode 19 fun fact about the number 19
that number was worn by one of the great
all-time New York Jets Keyshawn Johnson
none asks what wine goes well with
kimchi ma'am first of all before I
answer this question literally as I was
about to say ma'am I thought you know
what
this is a cool way to bring back some of
those Wine Library TV vibes next time
answer a wine question in the askgaryvee
show the wine will be here and I will
taste it and review it they're gonna
like that you're gonna like that
ma'am because I love that style of food
in general as a Russian immigrant
Belarusian immigrant we eat a lot of
pickled food food as well and so I and
pickles are literally some of my
favorite things in the world but there's
a couple different ways you can go but
for me high acid whites have done well
or oily thicker whites so I'm gonna give
you the recommendation of Valentina
white wine from Italy and Santa Barbara
ruse on or vionnet if you want to go USA
on the wine so those are your two little
suggestions Robert asks why do you
release the askgaryvee show in the
evening are you trying to target to use
those commuters Robert great question I
appreciate you having the respect in me
to think I have that much strategy I do
like to say everything I do is on
purpose this one though on the other
hand happens to completely be on the
heads of Zach not usually Zach actually
actually have very little to do with it
it has a whole lot to do with d-roc
who's on the other side of this and has
new everything with my schedule here we
are at 9:30 or 9:40 taping today's
episode yesterday why don't we take the
Iraq 1 p.m. yesterday obviously that
came out later
it's 948 I expect the Iraq specially
with only one video question today to
bang the soundness should be up by two
or three or one and will be out soon so
completely predicated on the insanity
that is my schedule
Dmitri asks how do you prepare for an
important keynote Dmitri the way I
prepare for a keynote is to think about
punching every audience member directly
in the mouth I look at the audience as
my enemy yet my child there's this kind
of weird mix between loving them with
all my heart and really wanting them to
get the message there's a disrespect and
there's a love and that mix is what I do
I literally am like a boxer before
hitting the ring six minutes before I
take stage maybe that's where Jab Jab
Jab right hook came from in some ways
because I'm literally in this crazy zone
eight minutes before I'm talking I don't
even know that I'm giving a talk I'm
like just like do my email I'm just like
laughing on the crying by the Jets like
you know whatever it is but around 6
minutes zone I go into this weird place
and I get very focused and I say to
myself you're only as good as your last
talk and so even though I've had a great
kind of 7 year public speaking career
none of that matters the second I take
that stage for the next time because
you're only as good as your last at-bat
and so my friend to answer your question
to be drink the way I prepare for a
speaking engagement is the same way I
would prepare for war Jared asks Gary
you said ignorant help you innovate in
marketing do you think any of your areas
of expertise hold you back from
innovating Jared thank you so much for
making the askgaryvee show what it is
for all you hardcore vayniacs and I've
appreciated all of you and by the way
all of you lurkers that means the people
watching this show on YouTube or
natively in Facebook because that's the
way I've been putting it out and are not
leaving comments are pissing me off so
lurkers
19 get your asses in the comment section
it is the fuel that helps me continue to
do the show jarred thank you for making
this show what it is and what I mean by
that is so many of you have heard if
you're hardcore about me which is that
MOT you know that medium post like you
know maybe want to put the picture of it
up here like you know me failing all my
classes is why I'm good right like my
lack of reading my lack of knowledge of
a lot of things that keeps me very
creative because I'm not folding into
things and using the same thing over and
over there's that it's a big advantage
for me my lack of education IQ knowledge
and a lot of subject matters really
helps me and so for the same reason I
say that Jared the answer is yes the
things that I believe in are more
knowledgeable about hold me back because
they get entrenched in my brain I
believe them to be the way they are now
because it's in my soul to fight and to
counteract and to go in the gray not the
black and white and all that stuff I
think I maybe get away with it a little
bit more but through this I'm still
human and yeah those things are holding
me back hey Gary my name is Mark source
ASIMO you might remember me from this
little incident please bye Gary's book
my life depends on it by it my question
for you today is this I have 39,000
Instagram followers instagram.com slash
mark and I average about 250 likes per
photo but I also run the Instagram
account before the company that I work
for we have a 6,000 followers and we
also average about 250 likes per photo
what am I doing wrong
on my personal account I must be doing
something right because I have the
follower account but they're not let's
get into this Oh mark couple things I do
remember you you know great dude thanks
for being on the show you know there's
two things that stand out it took a few
minutes to look because I wanted to give
a good answer here not just a general
answer number one Vimeo is a beloved
brand to that community more so than you
are to your community for a couple
reasons one I just think a lot of people
followed Instagram slash mark because
it's Instagram slash mark right you have
like like that's a that we saw that in
Twitter days the people that got there
like real names
have exponentially more followers
because we're like who are these people
before and in a world where Instagram
doesn't have verify there's like who is
this guy
I literally think some people find you
so they think you're Mark Sanchez or
some like other mark so I do believe
that you have an inflated number of
followers who actually don't give a
rat's ass about you but they're just
following you because of that name
that's not the disk but that's just what
I believe number two looking at the
accounts very easily and he brought put
up a little sample of votes right here I
don't know if you can frame it but like
you know and I don't maybe you can go
through like showing six of the photos
here so what casein difference
what do you see difference that's why we
keep Steve around for grammar what's the
difference you see in these things
here's the core thing Vimeo is putting a
ton of human beings in there pictures
you are not and I think a strategy of
making it more human not just landscape
and pretty pictures would really help
you don't forget Instagram is a platform
that there's a lot of human emotion to
it it's still a more authentic place
than some of the other social networks
though landscaping and beautiful
pictures work human over indexes and
more importantly you don't have a mix
the problem is you have a mix and I
think you need a mix of the two and so
those would be the core things that's it
right no more questions
very nice another episode in the books I
feel the momentum going
I feel the momentum going but I need
more distribution so the question of the
day is can we make a deal how do I get
my videos on your site your little blog
your company's blog let's make a deal
are you willing to make a deal with me
and number two because I'm noticing a
lot of the comments are based on the
question day which I love but unlike the
Wine Library TV audience there isn't
that core audience yet of fifty or
hundred people that are giving me
feedback on the show there's a little
group I want to expand that group I love
the people that really know my brand or
new people like hey I just stumbled on
you because of this and I really enjoyed
this that and the other thing the
feedback loop is my oxygen you keep
asking questions I will continue to
answer them